[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I think you guys can hear me
now Oh one day I will
hello well if it became spawn live third
time's the charm
welcome to give the spot line good
afternoon I hope you're doing well
we're playing
[Music]
all right yes hello welcome back to
GameSpot live where everything is
totally fine technologies on my site so
far again here we're gonna farm for eggs
so yeah let's do that shall we
holy Lord yeah when I first started this
dream I did not call for help
Ritchie helped me out and now we're good
so April 1st is actually huge right now
a lot of things are happening we are
switching seasons on in this place you
can see that all of your cheese
all of these just thought cherry
blossoms blossom petals oh my gosh I'm
so flustered right now with everything
that I'm like okay I know that might
need to be louder but there's some crazy
construction going on across the street
and I really don't want if you take over
the wait the airwaves but hopefully yeah
hopefully you don't hear the
construction too bad I did turn up the
mic though so yeah I apologize it
alright so a few new things are going on
with today one of them being the bunny
Day event is upon us
and a zipper our fifth house
zippity-doo-dah
I think that's all of them we do have an
article up right now
oops I've already pasted that
we have an article that's kind of
explaining what to expect with this
event and today in general because now
that March is gone all the merchants oh
[Music]
I miss my chance the bunny's scared oh
what a Bob Jones Tristen everybody I'm
so sorry my technical difficulties are
so horrible right now but hopefully this
is better actually I'll just move the
mic a little closer to thank you see you
can get what's going on because the eggs
are everywhere we've got to get them and
we've got to make all the bunny items
and then
[Music]
I don't know what it is I'm sure people
on there already have it by now I don't
want to get spoiled so please try your
best
no yeah I accidentally ran it do we know
what the cherry blossom leaves are for
so I know that there's a few recipes you
can find that are cherry blossom related
so yeah these ones cherry blossom petal
pile outdoor picnics at cherry blossom
o'clock and like this flooring but I
know there's more stuff I saw someone
who had a really really cute cherry
blossom wallpaper so I haven't collected
them all yet but you'll be able to get
recipe
too much too much yes actually made
sleeping on the job
I need the picnic set and pedals
[Music]
my peaceful garden so yeah this is the
picnic bed and you see over in between
the two trees is where I have the pebble
a pile Exmouth cool gamer it's your
birthday happy birthday man
awesome oh you made a cherry blossom
umbrella Gilbert I am jealous
that sounds really cute hey guys if you
want an island to go to today it's cool
gamers birthday if you put whoo dodo
code in the chat go visit him give him a
happy birthday write him a little
message on his wall
if you're open later I'll stop by in and
say happy birthday nah Jay says what's
the poisoning it's to live your best
life that is what's the point of this
business for sure
today we're just chilling out it's
Wednesday right when they would chilling
out
we're gonna go eggs I'm teen might hit
up a couple mystery islands and scavenge
some earth eggs there's already got all
the eggs off my Island today
[Music]
let's try to get as many of these bunny
recipes done and season I know it sounds
like a troll when I say just live your
best life but literally that's how I
feel when I play the state when I get to
make everything as pretty as I want to
make it I get to have my own mouth so I
get to have all these friends on my
village who who love me and it never
mean to me I just got my island as a
barrier so if you if you see an
excessive amount of heart-shaped funds I
can't help
I've only crafted a few egg things so
far size of the egg bed and I made an
egg outfit so let me see let me take let
me show you guys the egg recipes I have
so far so as a bunny day fends the stone
egg outfit I think these ones are the
ones that your character thinks up in
their head so you catch a certain number
of eggs and they'll be like oh I just
got a good idea for a DIY project and so
yeah because I got this one I got a
bunch of wood eggs and then this one
when I got a bunch of stone eggs there
is a bunny de Flore chloe garland for
your walls bunny day lamp that looks
literally just like a wood egg and the
day bed these are only only ones I have
so far by I know there's more I've only
crafted five of them I still have to do
these other ones so we've got a long way
to go
[Music]
what's up patch universe who says hello
from Belgium
well hello some San Francisco hope all
as well and hope you're staying safe out
there in the world happy Wednesday
you're like my homies chillin in the
play uh they're doing the stretches this
is one of my favorite things about it
come out and they do exercise and stuff
and it always reminds me I need to do
some stretches
[Music]
Oh another important thing to know is
that if you like you've been out there
you can access this unless you're
connected to the Internet time clock
so keep that in mind also you're either
not seen zipper in your island if you
going up the cherry blossoms Oh actually
my sucks cherry blossom if you don't see
zipper on your Island and that's why so
if you notice here trying to farm the
trees and stuff nothing's coming out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so Bob Jones with the blossoms you can
craft special things coming at unclean
dime skippers I mean it just being like
that
lil ma says my favorite childhood game
and it's back now to be your favorite
adulthood game isn't that amazing I am
believing for it yeah fuzzy catch those
blossoms homie can make all the cool
stuff I don't know how much they're
worth
[Music]
because I haven't tried to sell them yet
I've kind of been hoarding them let's
see how much they're worth for 800 so
they're like 200 okay like a regular
resource kind of the iron and that gets
are like 375 golden like it's like ten
thousand um you can make no [ __ ]
bigger by buying as many of the limited
items my island name is bandle city
because I love Teemo
my flag all hail tea alright enough
distraction back to the egg hunt
[Music]
I did make a flimsy axe so let's chop
some trees I actually haven't shaken
these gonna wild up as far as BC that's
my left
[Music]
and I put this fossil out here because
I'm gonna turn this whole area in front
of the museum Neal one of them had to
happen maybe star yes my island tune is
the Lost Woods so if you change your
island tune every time you talk to your
villagers it plays your island I love
like I'm already a sucker for like
customization type games where you can
just customize my boy
there we go yeah see you got a three my
luck is not so bad
[Music]
yes catch those wasps Sony's because
they're worth Melanie said hi is worth
like 200 and then the wasp itself I
think is like
[Music]
thank you I am obsessed with all the
clothing in this game hold up let me do
a little fashion show right quick so
this is my little flower power out of
that
I love I feel like I would wear this hat
it white bow like I like this link is
like so colorful just go back I would
totally wear I will wear all this stuff
[Music]
so cute and I put the little
I'm gonna sue the game oh this is the
one eggy outbreak that I I crafted I've
better got my wand because eventually
when I get all the eggs I want to put
them all on the blondes and just slicing
through all the eggs oh this little
heart dress is so cute and hilarious
because it has cleavage and then like
that my main main house is from King
high 3 justice all the Easter stuff
going on though I was like very slow
[Music]
alright alright some awesome friends who
let me take like a few fruits from their
Island and also got fruits from the mist
three islands that you've been in the
clouds so if I had ran into like all
these pear trees right here's our from
when I went to the misty island and it
was all Paris cuz my native through in
nature so I literally ate a bunch fruit
dug up all the trees and brought him
back to my
[Music]
so you gotta have the star want to you
to change your ounces and when you get a
recipe for a star one and then you have
to get star fragments to make the one
which if you look in your camera at the
night sky and see a shooting star then
you can luckily for me if Brandon's
match at Brandon ripped me up it my star
ones one flimsy accident I probably
[Music]
going to be farming everything
oh now you have these diva shout in your
face and I announce you diva gear just
makes for a perfect animal Crossing's
lab it really does burritos add the
bunny event is live yeah that's my bird
egg hunting I do not have a tick-tock I
know it's pretty massive I know it's not
a part of my mostly Twitter and
Instagram for me oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
not at all right we have a whole full
awesome squad of people who work on the
channel we all make awesome content goes
live on the channel everything stays so
you know we really are a huge team
effort thank you oh my gosh I have not
spent its ton of time remodeling the
inside of my house
but definitely gonna be a goal and
Abele's just sat down on my resources
all right keep it warm for me
[Music]
Brandel good afternoon welcome how do I
get the diva outfit so if you go onto
hashtag Animal Crossing designers the
whole community is making all these
really really cool designs most of the
ones I have on my magic wand right now
are all like ones I downloaded there's
only a few that I made myself so
definitely go check out that hashtag on
Twitter download some of the people are
making crazy stuff with the design
editor actually I found this really nice
website that like convictive images with
the tiny blade town flag of Teemo and it
came out way better than I thought it
was going to exciting I never found
money island do you see my my orangey
just but it's fine one day enough years
of me not finding it it means I have to
find it eventually oh my god I thought
that was the end of me right there what
the heck see I got too comfortable I got
I like just all the trees over here
except for this one are you serious but
ha no eggs but ha we survived
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all these pesky wasps that were chasing
thank you guys thank you so much for the
props on that catch I was terrified
that's like part of the reason why I
bought the weapon wheel sorry the tool
wheel yeah yeah it's hard not to cut a
weapon sometimes when I play something
creepy but yeah the tool wheel is clutch
for that so these fruits make some money
so oh I didn't go back and pick up oh
yeah I did
I'm saving giant clams right now cuz
there's some clam themed furniture I
just made the shell bouncing but there's
some plan themed furniture I'm trying to
make it's importing giant yeah I know I
can run inside a building but I want
those juicy bells they're worth like
2008 so sometimes I just risk getting
stung for all the bills but yeah that's
what I was doing in the beginning when I
just I couldn't catch them they were
hard to catch I either wait and figure
out how to do it rip and tear wheel yes
exactly
oh yeah they stopped jackhammering
outside except this crazy construction
going on outside and the last like week
or so they decided to introduce the
jackhammer into the mix Julie okay we
have it cleared up so I have 17 wood
eggs I think I think I have enough of
those for now
I made all these flimsy axes though
we'll go to a mystery islands and ep2
the resources so the ones that's
definitely going to take a while
I like the fishing water first trying ya
mother's a couple weeks even go about
getting the tarantula like you can just
walk up to them slowly with the net like
every time they have their hands up
stop watching when they put them back
down walk a little bit or you could do
like the fold diamonds and then go like
disturb it and then run back and then
you jump into the hole like if you leave
a little space in the middle and the
tarantula can't get you but that
requires you like Oh seeing the tranche
Allah and then going okay I'm setting it
up and then running back and getting it
when sometimes when you're just running
around they'll be one like right here
but you can't see because the cheese
[Music]
[Music]
eggie let go water and sky are the
scarce ones yeah I'm trying to keep my
eyes peeled for
[Music]
slight squeeze here
I spend too much time on this area but I
love it now
[Music]
let's go re-watch universe thanks for
hanging out thanks for watching much
appreciated definitely get some sleep um
I don't know if I'm going to open the
island later
[Music]
only because like when we streaming on
community Friday and literally to pass
the stream with people entering and
leaving
[Music]
Oh oh my gosh
my depth perception is not getting the
skin will admit that I'm always missing
of the neck oh that's but we'll still
take it there's firm as I'm looking for
guys in the chat let me know if you have
the recipe for an Ironwood dresser I'm
desperately looking for I have the
cutting board the dresser so with the
eggs you get to make all of the bunny
day themes of recipes
[Music]
yes you'll get all these bunny deenz
recipes that you can make with egg and
then you can make them all surprise
[Music]
[Music]
- I have a piggy me machete I have a
horse named Rene
[Music]
I never never had this many fish take
the first zipper okay he didn't take the
table so I bought the tool wheel which
you can buy from the Nook Terminal
forgot how many miles it I think I was
like 8,000 miles or something like that
egg in the bag Oh No
there's also like a 30-second stream
delay so I forgot I need to keep my arms
shoot
[Music]
I need the recipe for that ironwood
duster or if someone just has the
dresser
[Music]
No Oh is there another enough shop
upgrade um I'm not sure which one you're
referencing oh my pockets are full again
so much clutter puts all these axes I
forgot
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's impossible to be bad now I don't
own the actual ironwood dresser recipe
so I can't craft it even if I know what
it's for
what's required for it but that's why I
really like the catalog system I've been
buying furniture from friends and then
once I get it once it's always in my
catalog and if I want to go buy it again
I can just go to the terminal which i
think is super convenient all right let
me sell some of this definitely the
fishies let me go to my house and drop
off some of these resources trade
actually that was like resource oh you
can all right let me go outside and eat
one and see I haven't even tried I'm
just a hoarder I like to avoid them and
you just build stuff with them so I
didn't even think to eat it gonna be one
of these bad worthless just gives you
one power
good to know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
that's my living room this is my kitchen
[Music]
[Applause]
my bedrooms over here
[Music]
KJ fighters your favorite artist no gap
he was pretty legit I got these arcade
company now with a freaking love so hard
so great
[Music]
[Music]
I just made that out of the cherry
blossom petals cherry blossom petals so
make sure you catching those petals and
now I have a bathroom although I just
got it so um I don't know how much the
ironwood dresser is but it's in do you
like five thousand bells I don't think
it would be more than that getting like
barter they need to have like an auction
house somewhere an auction Islands where
you can go there you can fly there you
put some things up for auction hey
anybody that's in a bunch of
[Music]
alright we've cleared some space I'm
gonna go by Anna miles ticket yeah
you're gonna have more than one room you
just have to keep paying off your loan
and then like when you pay off your loan
he gives you another option upgrade then
you pay off your loan again and gives
you another option I'm still not even
totally maxed out I have some friends
who are like completely done they jet
they got really lucky in the stock
market sold their turnips for like a
massive profit
I'm talking like five times profit her
friend had turned upside like five
hundred eh on their Island she took all
their turnips over to their Island and
sold them all mean all the money paid
off all the bills and now she's living
your best life animal crossing in a
nutshell
Brandon Bivens what's up how's it going
all right so let's go to a mystery
island
I finally got the island editor so I
spent a lot of my miles on getting stuff
for that melody heck yes I will give you
all the cherries for an iron wood
dresser let me know
find me on Twitter send me message send
me your friend code that would be a
beautiful chain I'll even go pluck them
for you and take them to you Brandon
when I stream this again on my channel
I'm gonna do another I'll do an egg time
all right
Gavin free resources all the accesses I
might need another show
[Music]
if you need my handle melody it's at
Persia underscore X over here I'll
switch this really quick right here so
definitely send me that friend code so I
can get that dresser I will get you all
the cherries that you need I've been
trying to get that gesture back for a
while when I got the cutting board I was
so hype I was like oh snap
I'll be able to get the other one easy
peasy um the Easter event is like right
now you don't have to unlock anything
it's not a part of like the day-to-day
story
as far as I know I don't think it
requires like for instance Daisy may
only comes to your island if you level
up your enough shop so I don't know if
he has any specific specific things like
that but I don't think so my opinion of
Isabel and the doom Slayer is that I
cannot think of a more perfect combo I
love it I feel like those are my two
personalities actually like I'm half
team player I'm living for that combo
all the fan art and like I saw someone
had made literally an animation of them
and like Isabel just punched with the
same amount of power as doom guys
shotgun shoutouts to Jordan for noticing
that when I watch the clip the clip I
was like I was flabbergasted it was so
hilarious and I loved it um I can't flee
is off of one of my villagers which
sounds so messed up but you know last
time I caught a flee I was like earlier
today actually ooh
April's your birthday month Brandon are
you on areas when's your birthday
I wonder if Annabelle has more than one
flea on her she's the one I caught the
flea off of earlier I'll go catch him
off a very later
oh no I please all over my tips on
making tons of money
[Music]
some things that I do to like help me
make a lot of money as I've planted a
ridiculous amount of cheese like for a
while every time my fruit trees turn
fruit instead of eating or selling any
of that fruit I the fruit and then now
like whenever it grows back I just round
them all up to go and sell them except
for my native fruit else hoard those
until I can go to a friend's island and
sell them over there so I keep it
what else do I like to do for money
certain bugs are worth a lot like the
peacock butterflies the the wasps are
worth the one selling fish all of it
very great but we definitely have
content out right now in the channel
ways to make money fast so it's gonna be
more guides soon very very soon on other
ways
we have another guy coming really soon
from Jake you know really really rich
loo guarantee the other picnics it's so
cute I think it's like 10 bucks
now you see where the best birthday oh I
forgot I can eat the egg earlier oh
that's a tip right there you guys don't
break the the rock on the first go make
sure you didn't time the fruit stock tub
oh I hate that I hate when I do that
you're missing out on a lot of other
things you can get out of that rock
see ya
oh this one is cute I like this one ooh
oh wait this was the recipe that Teddy
gave me
I like to rack up some new smile
when you travel to you
with extra string exactly exactly
[Music]
a ladder was a recipe I got on like the
second or third yeah if I would have got
a fourth one I would have lost it
[Music]
the egg Ricci is ooh but has optimal
peanut butter to chocolate ratio
I'm still trying to get that community
leader
I feel like I'm close I must be I'm on
like the last one oh thank you if you're
gonna have the island open I'll mop in
there
[Music]
and I feel like the earth eggs and maybe
the leaf eggs are gonna be the hardest
one because the leaf eggs have to grow
on the tree Millicent says they got a
switch late for it and you got it just
in time because been really hard to find
switches now I have a lot of friends
who's been trying to get everything no
no I was wondering if it was gonna push
me too far
[Music]
see if you don't hit them in a rapid
enough succession you don't get all that
this there's definitely some optimal
rock mining
[Music]
[Music]
Wow a lot of
[Music]
these detainees honestly the big reason
why I wanted to get a regular switches
so that I could dock it when I wanted to
but I love all the colors yeah a little
bit of research I went you're finding
goes a long way so I'm glad is
I got that upgraded tool recipes after a
few days remember exactly who I got them
from I'm trying to think
nice camus very nice also shadow send
him for like reading the context clues
[Music]
played way too many hours with games 338
MA - day whoa oh
I do love you gotta stay strong
sometimes they just look so pretty that
I'm like
and also you guys if you're looking for
a friends if you're looking for people
to add if you're you know willing to
drop your friend code down in the chat
add each other on I know on Monday when
we streamed on Monday I went back and
added as many friend codes as I could
find so I'm definitely down to add
people you guys should add each other
because you really do get a lot more
resources and a lot more bang for your
buck so to say when you can travel to
your friends islands or have the most of
your eyelid gonna unlock special
achievements that'll give you more Nick
miles so you know we're all in this
together so go out there and make
friends honestly I feel like I struggle
making friends friends IRL by I made so
many friends through Animal Crossing
already that's it's pretty great
Fisher you're right yeah a little fish
turned around
All Right see you later cat thanks so
much for tuning in
good to see ya is that an egg I was some
sort of egg pun I swear these fish have
no peripheral vision
[Music]
ray said just got new fries in destiny
already sunk so many hours and seriously
and the other thing too like time just
flies when you're playing this will be
doing literally nothing but chopping
wood and then you're like what what
happened the last two hours of my life
I knew it yes some tips if you're
running from wasps like that make sure
you stop holding down run and turn
manually because if you run and you
don't give you this little skid action
but yeah see that little skid motion
there because I've done that before and
I did not recover in time
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes I'm seeing all the friend codes
come you look great
Rinat shuttle back a long time ago but I
never solved it whatever season they
came back with I definitely love hello
it's evil and I didn't say that right
but hello
alright that's the end of the lines on
my face all the
[Music]
my tree branch
[Music]
and I ate our thanks for tuning I'll you
to the ocean I can't help but feel like
I'm seeing literally everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh sorry firetruck is passing by
[Music]
cuckoo for milk elem salim or sell them
the truth
all right we out let's go craft some of
these recipes like just enough eggs the
event ends on the 12th I think so there
can't be too many records but they're
probably not doable recipes that you can
complete it all in one day
[Music]
alright let's go build watching the
stream I feel like I would be a horrible
distraction she looks so different you
bugs
throughout the seasons 38 recipes a
wowzers I'm behind I mean say it's
birthday boy I forgot I had this cake a
slider reggae track I'm out the register
that bad boy
[Music]
oh my god that is amazing
never carry mouth alright let's grab
some eggy things some excellent recipes
Sheldon I already have the Mantis so
it's fine all right I definitely was
[Music]
there must be some sort of oh my guess
this crown would go with everything
bunny day since Brandon says should I
buy this never played an animal crossing
I feel like this game is definitely for
a specific type of person like if you
find this type of thing therapeutic I do
I've played a lot of games like this
like a play I played a ton of Kingdom
for Catholics back in the day which was
all literally hoard resources and build
things not as in-depth as this obviously
but it was just along those lines like I
find games like that very therapeutic
and I play a lot of multiplayer games
like fighting games
like SPS and like all these very
stressful games it's nice to have a game
that I could just chill out not have to
be a try-hard in even though low-key I'm
trying really hard in this game to yeah
you get the recipes from a bunch of
different sources actually you can get
them from your villagers the same way
they run up to you and teach you like
reactions and stuff so I'll do that and
give you recipes you can get them out of
egg themed balloons that you see flying
you'll either get a sky edge or recipe
and yeah wait things like that will help
you get the recipes if you want a friend
people on this game you have to add them
with their switch code on your actual
device on the console and then when you
go into the game you'll be able they can
open their island and you can go to
their Island the first time you both of
your characters on the same island you
can send them a best friend invite via
your nook phone in the game so that's
how you can add people I really like
this color scheme right here
[Music]
[Music]
throw oh this is what I like this is why
I got on the island when I shook the
tree yeah I am the epitome of a trihard
I'm talking about stone farming optimal
stone farming Zach and tech recovery
times on caching loss Danny why are you
exposing me I love it
perfect All Right see you later Garrett
thanks for stopping by
I'll just catch you next time happy
Wednesday
oh yeah ray that is true like if you're
trying to find a specific fish I would
not be doing it during this event
because all you're gonna get our eggs 12
so far someone said there's 30 does
anyone know if you can get a cat in
Animal Crossing
I know there is a paper cat I don't know
if you can get like a real live pet cat
which is really weird because one of the
first free pieces of furniture I got it
was like a cat post thing and I was like
this is awesome if I can get an actual
like pet cat I can run on it so yeah I'm
not sure actually if anybody in the chat
knows no issues crafting so I have a
[Music]
stone outfit I need earth
guy outfit water outfit boy boy so much
[Music]
yeah that's all I got so far
cool you know what in honor I want to
wear the the pretty blue and green one
the leaf egg outfits three these sticks
are 38 and it's old all yeah
if Ritchie's still in the chat hit up
the chat with those sweet sweet links to
all of our guides we have a ton of
really really useful guides on the
YouTube channel and on the website right
now and also now and also we have more
on the way I want to put my egg yeah
this one's so cute I also have this oh I
love it I have any colorful glass Cystic
I always buy glasses for any character
it's green ones it's not the same green
though
whatever we're wearing oh not in saves
so cute I love this I have any cute like
oh that's adorable see you guys the
scheme is just amazing I wanna pet
hamsters so bad my friend has a pet
hamster at her house
they made it so cute oh yeah you can
plan my tree if you pick up money and
plant Tim Kay in that hole that you dug
it out of a tree will grow and sprout
three times as much alright so we made
lots of things
we're diddly our goal now is water sky
so sky would definitely up to be on my
own islands I have to just walk around
find balloons water I could do on a
mystery Island or here definitely do it
here my god the earth one I would
definitely have to go to Mystery Island
so I'll save that one we'll go fishing
let's go oh snap fooey is about to open
their gates if anybody wants to get
those miles in and go give Fuli a visit
keep an eye out praise that dodo code
[Music]
Stefan I'm gonna be some persona stuff
we do have a little bit of persona stuff
up already shoutouts to Michael holdin
it down putting in like so many
operatives how many islanders Ricky like
well over 100
[Music]
I'm slightly OCD so I literally can't
run around I'm just gonna buy it because
I'm bougie like that now you can always
plant more trees but if you start
getting your Island hobby wanting like
right now I don't want to chop down any
of my trees because I have ton of fruit
trees I have a decent amount I was like
regular trees I have bamboo shoots and
stuff but you know I want to keep those
on my legs like still want to grow lots
of fruit so I can have some money make
those and stuff like that so I just go
to the Mystery Island and chop trees
there instead or if you need would use a
flimsy axe so your tree won't actually
get chopped down but you'll still get
[Music]
nice area all these axes I went overkill
on the axes whatever I crafted them saw
technique
Oh Louise reopening the gates there was
something so he's gonna post a new code
[Music]
oh no teddy has please I see it on I
miss their pose wait teddy let me help
you
[Music]
should I give it back to them oh sorry
if I had given him back the flea will he
catch it again because I already took
[Music]
Denny look if you're still here
Teddy said that he hopes you come back
big same all right who else has fleas
who else who do I need to exterminate
[Music]
see you later Brandon have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
I already caught a clownfish but this is
the first time I cut it on my island
must be a please let's be a private of
seasonal changes
[Music]
yeah oh my gosh the anticipation like so
intense the egg baited me that many
times so messed up
[Music]
I want to live a happy life however if
you guys want to laugh and also if you
want to watch something funny go check
out our new let's play series from Rob
and where they do a dirty RTS series
called the vile villager that's pretty
much everything wrong you can do is your
village you guys should check that out
the first episode is already
so at a certain point you can get ramps
and stuff from residence services you
have to level up resident services first
and get ramps and get bridges
like he gives you one bridge early on
but they're really expensive to make
after you get that first one
oh the shadows like them huh let's see
what we got you recipe new recipe yeah
all right cool
count it add it to the board this is as
close as you're gonna get to frosting
any type of shooting weapons
[Music]
oh definitely need a few more loads
this works like a big one but once you
just see it to be bad
I knew it I'm a leg oh he turned at the
last second ruining my fishing streak I
am stuck on the cast master on the last
one you had like 500 in a row look at me
look at my bait dang it's such a weird
angle
all right that's AB right there
Oh Mike he's just giving me the cold
spin now there we go
only ten million Charlie there we go the
eggs are baiting me super hard
Oh No
what's wrong oh sure I think what
they're thinking and they're like I went
over lay like what did I do wrong
I'm sorry absolutely I actually goofed
super hard
oh hi tuna
not what I was expecting to catch but
I'm very glad I have this huge patch of
flowers on the front of my my island and
I popped a balloon while standing in the
middle of it and since there was no
empty space for it to fall it just
disappeared so be careful if you do
something like that like think of every
way you could do something wrong in this
game and I've probably done it it was
twice I also dropped the present in the
water on accident I got an achievement
for hilarious or an OOP miles of human
butt
[Music]
hae-jin Melford yes all the officers
that's the first time I thought that one
[Music]
since I started about 10 minutes late
I'm gonna keep running the stream for
another 10 minutes or so technically I
started on time I just have the wrong
setting
but official live broadcasting I love
doing these spinning okay so I only got
one more recipe than what I had I think
it's at the top yeah
Suleiman you could definitely waste so
many hours on this
I like all those stools literally just
the egg on its side and maybe a little
tiny bit wider so funny well I can make
that right
all right let's go make an exit tool
place it by the egghead however make
sure you put your friend code in the
chat before you go because I'm gonna go
back and add everyone so please please
please leave leave the digits all right
[Music]
and everyone else should add each other
to end with a run through the museum
100% I'm going to do that because I've
been working so hard on my knees damn
you guys super super hard I went in went
shark fishing on my friends southern
hemisphere island last month for hours
to try to get all the Sharks for the
fish Nate and I dude they also like
Nathan's IRL so it's kind of a nice it's
really cute I want to even make a school
in every egg color that would be nice
cool so let's go drop this
[Music]
reminds you a lot of Minecraft dude
totally
I've played minecraft before never the
actual normal mode just like the sandbox
where you can knock stuff down and build
stuff because I just love doing things
like that
so I definitely get five like this
especially when you have the island
editor and you can like create and
delete cliffs it's crazy it's wonderful
[Music]
I wonder which tank they're gonna put
him in oh I forgot I didn't donate the
Pilchuck yet I had caught him before all
right so it's tour time I'm gonna go
bugs first because that's what I have
the least of how do you plant fruit make
sure you dig a hole with your shovel and
then while your shovels equipped plant a
fruit into the wall so bugs I still need
to catch a lot of them I've caught quite
a few butterflies so far but there's
still a ton of bugs I'm missing
they've been third on the list I just
got this colorful one today the one at
the top of the screen she just flew out
of view there she is I just caught her
today I think she's new a part of April
exciting first time you played Minecraft
you were stuck on it for days heck yeah
this is my favorite bug so far the
orchid mantis yeah these are all empty
and goes I'm a loser except I have some
more fruit is in there so I'll see this
the aquarium
like the like the aquarium it's the most
visually striking the Dino one is great
because I have a lot of it completed I'm
missing like a t-rex tail if you just
started the game a lot of these recipes
come after it like the first few days so
don't feel like oh man I don't know like
where this is or how to get this or how
to get that because you might actually
like just not you might not be able to
get it yet so so yeah first room of
fossils completed the amber up there in
the top left that was the last one I
needed for this room but well really
awesome so beautiful I don't even know
what this looks like cucumber and then
the Dino room I have a lot of these bad
boys done are close to done but my t-rex
he has no tail I'm still missing a wing
on the sky - I think I'm obviously
missing this guy's hind legs was i gay
he's still beautiful I finish this guy
but you can't see him unless you
actually look at the title yeah my t-rex
tail is missing yeah
[Music]
I'm not finalized yet on tomorrow's game
but we will definitely be life tomorrow
there's a lot of awesome games coming
out this week and next week so
definitely tune would be great to have
you any day of the week
we're live every weekday the only
privacy Rex you have is the tale Ritchie
oh we need to combine forces I can't
find it all right
and then my favorite part of the whole
museum the aquarium I love it
the Ivan I mean so much fun like filling
up the museum my favorite part of the
whole game actually it's very peaceful I
like the music they play inside the
museum
it looks very visually striking and then
that sense of accomplishment you get out
of walking in seeing that it's full and
yeah I just got these little touched
neon tetras today I think they're a part
of the new fish rotation awesome
oh look a little crawfish blood Berea's
yeah yay he has a home all you said
what's up you saw that he put his fins
in the air his little claws yeah I don't
know what else is gonna go in here but
this is a big ol tank and there's only
one fishy in there right now so he's
living large meanwhile all these pretty
ones are all stick hekia must complete
all right my favorite favorite part of
the whole museum my favorite tank the
shark tank it's so pretty I love it so
much when I caught the ocean fish which
is the big ol circular fish right there
going by I flipped out I could not
believe that thing came out of the water
oh the Erawan it goes in there I have
not all those yet but yeah I love this
one so much the windows the villagers do
go into the museum and it's so cute cuz
when you walk in and they're looking at
stuff and you talk to them they're like
oh I saw you donated this thank you so
much and like they give you your props
I'm like oh and then this is my second
favorite tank in the aquarium the one
that you can run through
in the hammerheads in this one ah it's
so peaceful oh and I finally got Dory I
had Nemo and Marlin in here for a bit
and now I have Dory yay the whole gang
is here all right you guys I'm gonna go
back to the shark tank these things are
pretty but I have one in my room and if
you turn on the light it does some crazy
crazy like getting the formation it
looks a little scary but they're cute
when they're floating normally yeah the
orange or fish freaked me on to you I
have an oarfish they put it what what's
crazy to me is they put him in a really
tiny tank look how tiny this tank looks
like he needs more space he looks so sad
it's okay buddy all right guys that is
gonna be it we're gonna take one
snapshot for the gram you want ready no
get it all ready guys thank you so much
for everything thank you for tuning in
and hanging out going egg hunting with
me yo zipper is in the chat zipper we
were doing all this for you man look at
my outfit inspired and by your sweet
sweet designs thank you guys so much for
tuning in and hanging out
I'm loving this game it's absolutely
amazing it's definitely up my alley
so hopefully you guys who are also
playing put your friend codes in the
chat so that I can add you after this
melody I'm definitely gonna hit you up
so I can get that iron wood dresser but
yeah aside from that thank you guys so
much for tuning in don't forget we are
live every
single weekday at 2:00 p.m. Pacific time
we play all kinds of stuff not just
animal crossing so if this wasn't your
thing today check back tomorrow might be
something a little bit more for you you
just have to be here to find out so
thank you guys for tuning in and I will
catch you next time
happy Wednesday guys have a good one
stay safe we love you see you soon
you